hi this is press talker this map problem
went viral after it's dumped many
seventeen and eighteen year olds in
Australia can you figure it out a 50
cent coin has 12 sides of equal length
what is the angle theta formed when the
two coins are placed next to each other
on a table is it 12 degrees 30 degrees
36 degrees 60 degrees or 72 degrees give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching the video for the solution
so there are many different ways to
solve this problem I'm going to go over
two ways that I thought about solving it
so we just had Halloween and one method
to solve this is to use a ghost coin
we'll remove the table and we'll make
another copy of the second coin now
let's translate this coin down and
you'll see that in the center is a
triangle formed by three of the sides of
the three coins so this triangle has all
of its sides equal to each other
and therefore it's an equilateral
triangle and each of its angles are 60
degrees therefore we can conclude the
answer is 60 degrees a more conventional
method is to consider exterior angles if
we extend the side between the two coins
that are touching the angle formed on
the outside is known as an exterior
angle in our diagram we have two
exterior angles and the angle we want
theta is equal to the sum of two
exterior angles now what's neat is we
can figure out what the value of the
exterior angle is in any polygon the
exterior angles always add up to 306
degrees you can think about this
intuitively because if you make one trip
around a polygon you always end up back
in the same spot and one trip around is
360 degrees so the measure of a single
exterior angle will be 360 divided by 12
because a 12 sided coin will have 12
exterior angles so a single exterior
angle is 30 degrees and that means 2
times an exterior angle or theta will be
60 degrees so we get to the same answer
did you figure it out thanks for
watching this video please subscribe to
my channel I make videos on math and
game theory you can catch me on my blog
mind your decisions which you can follow
on Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
also catch me on social media at presh
tal Walker and if you liked this video
please check out my books I write many
books about math puzzles and other
interesting math topics there are links
in the video description